pour en parler nous sommes avec mériadec
raffray il est journaliste spécialiste
des questions de défense
secrétaire général de l'association des
journalistes de défense mais avec
raffray merci d'être en direct avec nous
sur rt france alors malgré plusieurs
déclarations politiques hier soir aucune
officialisation de la part du
gouvernement français ou maliens sur une
libération de ce fip et rona est ce que
cela est inquiétant
bonsoir olivier tout d'abord c'est une
affaire compliquée et on voit bien que
ces derniers 24 heures il ya eu
plusieurs rebondissements certains
annonçaient la libération de sophie
petrona dont évidemment on se réjouir et
je rappelle qu'elle a 75 ans qu'elle est
en étant détenu depuis le 24 décembre
2007 précisément donc certains l'annoncé
on voit bien que c'est compliqué je
pense que des prêts paris exerce
évidemment des pressions importantes
puisque les la communication djihadiste
est à dire et demi s'est elle aussi mise
en branle à l'annoncé et près de 200
djihadistes libéré en contrepartie de la
libération ce film patronat et de
soumaïla cissé je vous rappelle aussi
qu'il est otage ancien premier ministre
en tout cas ce que moi je note c'est que
dans cette affaire à nouveau pari est en
réaction et non pas un anticipation sent
bien que paris n'est pas dans le coup
paris subit je vous rappelle que début
août les coups il ya eu un coup d'état
militaire et tous les experts sont
d'accord pour dire que paris n'a rien vu
venir non plus c'est inquiétant de ce
point de vue là et enfin si on extrapole
ce qui pourrait se passer si on
extrapole une libération de ce filtre
petronas est évidemment un point bon
point pour le gouvernement qui de cette
manière marque son territoire reprend
prend prend toute sa dimension en jouant
cette carte on peut aussi voir l'autre
côté de la carte à savoir qu'ils vont
passer un accord avec le fameux
djihadistes qaïda ghali qui est l'homme
cible numéro un des français c'est lui
qui en avril dernier ouvert
officiellement un canal de négociation
avec bamako
pour l'instant il ne s'est rien passé
mais évidemment c'est une très mauvaise
nouvelle pour les français c'est une
presque une prise à revers ou 1 est un
échec ce serait un échec stratégique
pour les français parce que justement
paris qui subit alors qu'ils négocient
directement avec les preneurs d'otages
est ce que vous avez des informations à
ce sujet là non j'ai pas d'informations
et ces voix là c'est pour l'instant
c'est compliqué il y avait il ya sans
doute plusieurs cas nous d'ouvrir des
canaux officiels officieux mais c'est
plutôt le mali où il se serait plutôt le
mali où la france finalement alors j'ai
essayé ça me paraît assez évident que le
mali et en étant en pôle position la
france j'espère en tout cas joue un rôle
il ya un pays dont on peut parler aussi
olivier qui me paraît important à
souligner c'est l'algérie les experts
savent bien que si il y à dagahaley est
a miraculeusement échappé à la cible de
nos forces spéciales en particulier
c'est parce qu'il est protégé de
notoriété publique par l'algérie
l'algérie n'a jamais accepté le dit pas
mais l'algérie n'a jamais accepté que la
france revienne jouer dans son
arrière-cour stratégique dans son pré
carré c'est à dire au mali en
particulier au nord donc semble que
l'algérie est également à la manoeuvre
et je pense que l'algérie serait très
heureuse de marquer ce point dans le dos
des français donc c'est aussi évidemment
le calame un facteur qui est pas
terrible pour les français mais surtout
olivier si vous me permettez
cela aurait deux conséquences pour la
france d'une part ça va la forcer à
accélérer les séries billon stratégique
s est évidemment pour la france une
mauvaise nouvelle pour le récit qu'elle
nous sert depuis des années dans cette
fameuse guerre de sept ans cette guerre
du sahel de sept ans on nous explique
que la france est là pour casser les
reins des jihadistes pendant que l'état
malien et les politiques maliens se
remettre en selle
on voit bien que les choses sont
beaucoup plus compliquées ça c'est la
première chose est sûre le plan
opérationnel évidemment imaginer si des
dizaines de jl djihadistes était
officiellement libéré selon à cela
serait un très mauvais signal envoyé à
nos militaires qui se battent
je vous le rappelle pour rétablir la
confiance c'est quoi c'est pour gagner
le coeur des populations pour dire aux
populations qui sont toujours les otages
de ces guerres
en vétérans 2 contre le terrorisme pour
leur dire elles se battent pour leur
dire soyez avec nous nous représentons
la force légitime et d'état malien et la
paix or la libération de ces djihadistes
sera évidemment le cas le signal
contraire envoyée à toutes ces
populations qui sont toujours les otages
de ces de ces guerres je vous rappelle
que les djihadistes évidemment se noie
se cache dans la population pour pouvoir
exister enfin dernier point cette si
cette libération intervenait avec ses
contreparties c'est à dire c'est ces
libérations de djihadistes ce serait
évidemment une victoire pour les
djihadistes la guerre antiterroriste est
une anna frottement de volonté comme
disent les militaires et en plus que les
djihadistes ont le temps pour eux ce que
les démocraties occidentales
non pas vraiment justement pour éviter
un tel scénario est ce que la france
pourrait payer une rançon par exemple on
sait qu officiellement ça ne se fait pas
mais est ce que ça peut être une
solution justement pour éviter ce
scénario
alors effectivement officiellement les
états la france ne paye pas de rançon
on sait très bien les spécialistes
savent bien qu'on ne libère pas un otage
ci est le dernier otage français détenu
dans le monde une femme de 75 ans à fort
pouvoir symbolique et émotionnelle
auprès de nos populations
on sait très bien tous très bien que ce
type de libération exige toujours des
contreparties qui est en général elles
sont souvent indirects voilà c'est n'y a
pas officiellement effectivement il n'y
a pas forcément de comment dirais-je de
l'intervention directe de l'état
français mais il ya souvent des
contreparties indirects en tout cas
cette libération à ce que pourrait
donner plus de crédibilité à la junte ou
au gouvernement de transition en place
au mali qu'ils ont quelque chose à tirer
aussi dans ce dossier oui c'est ce que
je vous disais tout à l'heure au
préambule rapidement c'est évident que
si le jeune pouvoir en place le
gouvernement de banda aux marques ce
point c'est un crucial pour établir sa
stature danser dans ces régions où la
discussion le palabre les dialogues sont
importants
sa marque aurait évidemment leur
capacité à dialoguer ce sont des
militaires mais dont qu'ils auraient
cette capacité à dialoguer y compris
avec l'ensemble des partis il y a eu
déjà de l'or des différentes guerres
entre le nord et le sud
depuis les années 60 plusieurs accords
qui ont été conclus comme cela c'est là
qu'on s'est mis autour d'une table ou
dans le désert en tout cas et on a
dialogué donc c'est dans le c'est dans
les gènes de cette région et puis et
puis alors cela voudrait dire en même
temps que la paix serait faite sur le
dos enfin serait fait avec les
djihadistes avec le premier d'entre eux
le plus ancien il ya la galerie et ça
pour le coup c'est une alors c'est une
bonne nouvelle pour le gouvernement
malien mais c'est une mauvaise nouvelle
pour la région
cela supposerait que aneta
officiellement passe un pacte avec ceux
qui aujourd'hui sont présentés par
l'ensemble des experts comme les
principaux terroriste régionaux à grand
merci mériadec raffray pour votre
éclairage rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste spécialiste des questions de
défense secrétaire général de
l'association des journalistes de
défense